[Musik]
und welcher beruf ist das roboter in
ganzen satz bitte die frau die den helm
trägt ist eine bauarbeiter bauarbeiter
sehr gut was ist das besondere an den
fotos die ich eben gezeigt habe alle
sind verkleidet
wieso naja bauarbeiter ist an berufe
männer und im kindergarten arbeiten
meistens nur frauen nicht ganz viele
männer sind bauarbeiter und viele frauen
sind kindergärtnerinnen aber das sind
berufe die im prinzip jeder lernen kann
durak ans bauarbeiten werden wenn du
gerne möchtest und duah lernen kannst
erzieher in einem kindergarten werden
wenn du ist ihr könnt die berufe lernen
die euch interessieren und die euch spaß
machen egal was es ist
so schaut bitte auf die arbeitsblätter
dich ausgeteilt habe
[Musik]